I love your work so much I'm gonna kick
it off and start it with because it
would be a crime not to the office great
what's the first thing that comes
when I say the office I think of Dwight
schrute's orange shirt his like mustard
yellow shirt I mean look at you you're
so beautiful you think of Dwight's
orange shirt in his short sleeved like
orange mustard shirt is rain Wilson
anything like his character oh my God
nothing good to know yes okay the
morning show the best show ever like how
many fabulous women can you pack into
one cat what's a day on the set like of
the morning show I mean I've only been
on the show like just a handful of times
but I've done my scenes with Jennifer I
did a scene with Jennifer Aniston who I
know you what's it like to be in a scene
with Jennifer Aniston I mean she's I
hope this is okay to objectify it isn't
this is one of those things that will
just instantly get me canceled
obviously she's a great actress she's
had a very interesting life and great
movies and TV shows her body is so good
she looks so good it's like breathtaking
I know and it's a kind of good that you
can't even like ask her like how do you
look so what do you do because you're
like this is just a lifelong commitment
yes to just looking hot as hell and she
has said like when I feel like having a
cheat day I eat one potato chip or like
a one m m and I'm like well then that's
how you get that yeah because I'm going
whole bag okay The Mindy Project I mean
Hello that was something that
on this show like four times yes and
this this he's the person I think of
when I think of this show because he was
a writer director an actor on the show
he was with me 24 7. he lives three
streets away from me and he actually has
a broken neck and he decided to still
work even though he was healing from a
broken neck how did he break his neck he
was on the set of a movie and like fell
off a bridge oh God and so they that was
during our Hiatus when he came back he
had to wear the brace and we're like you
know what Morgan's just gonna have a
broken neck are you okay acting like
that and he was like yeah I love it so I
just love those kind of comedians who
are like yeah put me in there I have a
broken neck no problem ugh that is a
team player he's a team player okay
Ocean's eight yes
I mean kind of like the morning show
where you're just like
like hi Kate Blanchette Sandra Bullock
and Hathaway Helena Bonham Carter Sarah
Paulson and Rihanna I'm just in a room
with them what was that like
um
I have to say and I hope this doesn't
sound like
I don't know like sappy it was very
inspiring to be around so I'd come from
my show or is the star of the show and I
had lots of lines and everything and
then I went into this where I had a much
smaller part and I think there are times
when we've been the leads and things and
times when we haven't and I don't know I
like to be the actor that's like there's
no small parts but sometimes there are
small parts and you just want to
complain and you're really bored on set
and I've learned so much from this not
just acting obviously from Kate and
Sandy and Sarah and everyone else but
about how they run their families
because when actors go to shoot a movie
they're like bye to their families and
their family stay at home and they'd go
to you know Lake Como or Japan or
whatever and shoot and when actresses go
to City movie performance they take
their whole Community with them so our
base camp was like full of kids and
husbands and wives and tutors and I
really thought that was so powerful that
they're like no we just are bringing our
family and they just make it work okay
that is not the takeaway I expected to
hear and I love it so much you know what
I mean
there are times and of course I'm like
please get me out of here I want a girls
weekend to Cabo
and I and I do those in FYI yeah I'm I
do girls weekends in Cabo with your
friend Cameron Diaz and maybe you and
Dad and maybe me one day
um okay another Reese Witherspoon Oprah
Winfrey A Wrinkle in Time I really
I really been with like every A-list
actress except for you in a movie you're
the one actress that I haven't been in a
movie with all I want to do is be with
you so if it's in a movie or in Cabo I'm
there
okay
listen
I could get a trainer
we need to talk
like Sam Rockwell in that movie was like
my sexual Awakening he was so I feel
like you really made him hot thank you
thank you yes I know he loves dancing I
know but I would just I if like if I
would love to hear like what you think
are Charlie's Angels three would be and
then like go make it happen what a dream
okay anyway I dream I'm like let's call
Cameron and Lucy and make this happen
all right for more from the mind of
Mindy Kaling check out Mindy's book
Studio it's her very own imprint at
Amazon publishing full of great reads
hand-picked by Mindy herself that's
right now the brilliant writer is
literally lifting up other brilliant
writers
[Music]
foreign